A watch can survive a dive and still fail its diver.
If you cannot read it, what good is it?
Underwater, the task sounds simple.
Look at your wrist.
Find the minute hand.
Work out how long you have been down.
But light changes, your surroundings move, and a dial
designed for an office can become a puzzle.
The Rolex Submariner was built around that world: a watch
case that resisted water, a display that could be read
quickly, and a rotating ring that made elapsed time
visible. Those details eventually became a familiar
look far beyond diving.
How did a practical instrument acquire that kind of reach?
The answer begins with people learning to breathe
underwater. And later, it takes a surprising
detour to the deepest part of the ocean, where the
Rolex attached to a submarine was a very different watch.
In nineteen forty-three, French engineer Émile Gagnan and
naval officer Jacques-Yves Cousteau built an autonomous
compressed-air diving apparatus. The device became
known as the Aqua-Lung.
A diver could carry a supply of air and move without a
breathing hose running back to the surface.
That freedom opened possibilities for exploring, filming
and working below the waves.
During the following decade, scuba diving attracted a
wider public. More people were preparing equipment,
boarding boats and discovering a landscape they had
previously seen from above.
Taking a watch along made practical sense.
It supplied a reference for how much time had passed,
something a written plan could not show on its own.
But a watch was one part of the equipment.
Its hands could not report how much air remained in a
cylinder. For the watch itself to be useful, its mechanism
had to survive the place where its owner wanted to use it.
Every ten metres of descent adds roughly another
atmosphere of pressure. The farther down an object
goes, the more strongly the surrounding water presses
against it. For a wristwatch, that turns small
openings into serious design problems.
A crown has to move so the owner can set the hands, yet
the case around it must keep water away from the
mechanism. Rolex already had a foundation.
Its Oyster case dated to nineteen twenty-six, using a
sealed construction to protect the movement.
Developing a diving watch meant taking that idea into a
more demanding environment. According to Rolex,
Royal Navy divers tested Oyster Perpetual watches during
exercises from HMS Reclaim in Scotland's Loch Fyne
in nineteen fifty-two. The brand records
depths of up to seventy-three metres.
That account describes watches working underwater.
The next question was how to build their use into the
design.
Rolex dates the launch of the Submariner to nineteen
fifty-three. Its initial water-resistance rating
was one hundred metres, and its screw-down crown
used the Twinlock sealing system.
The new watch brought its underwater purpose onto the
wrist: a clear dial, prominent hands and a rotating
scale around the face.
You could look at it and see what it was meant to do.
There were other designers pursuing that purpose.
Blancpain dates its Fifty Fathoms to the same year.
Several companies were shaping the equipment that would
become familiar to divers.
A claim about being first can overshadow the more useful
question: did the design work well for the person using
it? A depth rating answered something about the case.
It did not answer everything about the display.
For that, Rolex's own account points to an engineer who
spent time below the surface.
Dimitri Rebikoff was an engineer, diver and
underwater photographer. According to Rolex, his
feedback followed one hundred and thirty-two dives at
depths between twelve and sixty metres.
One recommendation concerned a tiny triangle.
The marker on the rotating bezel was red.
Rebikoff suggested making it white to improve legibility.
There is a reason colour behaves differently down there.
Water filters light as depth increases, and red
wavelengths disappear more quickly than blue.
The appearance of an object depends on the light available
to reflect from it.
The important detail in Rolex's account is the feedback
itself. Someone used the watch in the environment it
was designed for, then suggested a change to what the
diver actually saw. A small marker could carry a
large responsibility: letting the wearer find the starting
point quickly. Once that starting point was clear,
the rotating scale could do its work.
Picture a simplified modern dive-watch dial.
The minute hand points to twenty past the hour.
Rotate the bezel until its zero marker lines up with that
hand. Now let the hand move.
The bezel stays where you set it.
Its scale shows how many minutes have passed since that
starting point. That is the basic idea of the Submariner's
elapsed-time bezel. A movable reference sits
beside a moving hand, so the wearer can read the interval
directly. On today's Submariner, the bezel turns
only counterclockwise. If it shifts accidentally,
the indication moves toward more elapsed time, rather than
less. The design makes that particular error conservative.
This is a time display.
It does not measure air supply, choose a safe depth or
calculate a complete dive plan.
But it makes one piece of information easier to read.
The next challenge was keeping that information available
as the watch itself evolved.
Rolex reports that the Submariner's rating reached two
hundred metres within a year of launch.
Later changes arrived along different paths.
The Submariner Date appeared in nineteen sixty-nine.
Its rating increased to three hundred metres in nineteen
seventy-nine. The model without a date reached that
rating in nineteen eighty-nine.
Those dates matter because a familiar name can hide
several generations of design.
A feature on today's watch cannot simply be assigned to
the original. The numbers also describe the watch's water
resistance. They are not instructions for how deep its
owner should go. A useful way to read the progression
is as a history of the object: its case, seals
and display developed while its basic purpose remained
easy to recognise. Yet Rolex's most
dramatic ocean story took the brand far beyond those
ratings. And it can lead people to mix up two very
different objects.
On January twenty-third, nineteen sixty, Jacques Piccard
and U.S. Navy Lieutenant Don Walsh descended
aboard the bathyscaphe Trieste to Challenger Deep
in the Mariana Trench, nearly eleven kilometres below
the surface. A Rolex watch travelled on the outside
of the vessel. Rolex identifies it as the Deep
Sea Special, an experimental model designed for
enormous pressure. That distinction is essential
to the Submariner's story.
The watch mounted outside the Trieste was
the Deep Sea Special.
The dramatic expedition does not establish an
eleven-kilometre rating for a Submariner on someone's
wrist. The two objects show different ambitions
within the same company's ocean work: an experimental
instrument facing extreme depth, and a wristwatch
designed for use by divers.
The title's real question comes back here.
How did the Submariner conquer the deep?
Its answer lies in making a useful wrist instrument,
while specialised challenges continued to produce
specialised watches.
The Sea-Dweller, introduced in nineteen sixty-seven,
addressed another requirement of professional diving.
In saturation diving, divers spend extended periods in
pressurised environments using breathing mixtures that can
include helium. Helium can enter a watch case.
When the surrounding pressure falls during decompression,
gas trapped inside can create a damaging pressure
difference. Rolex's helium escape valve
let that excess gas leave the case.
It was a response to the conditions of a particular kind
of work. The broader lesson is that diving equipment
developed through specific problems.
One situation demanded a readable time scale.
Another demanded a way to release internal gas pressure.
Those solutions should not be folded into a single
legendary watch with every capability.
The Submariner already had a clear purpose of its own.
Then its appearance began reaching people who might never
have a reason to descend below the surface.
In nineteen sixty-two, Sean Connery wore a Submariner in
the first James Bond film.
The watch's recognisable design could now reach a cinema
audience as part of a character associated with danger
and confidence. That connection helps explain its cultural
life. A practical object can become a symbol when
people recognise the activities and characters attached to
it. But return to the diver from the opening.
The useful question is still whether the wearer can find
the hand, see the marker and read the interval.
The Submariner's story connects those small acts to a much
wider world: the growth of scuba, feedback
from underwater use, changing case designs and the
reach of cinema. Its conquest of the deep is a
story of adaptation. A familiar shape carried the evidence
of the job it had been designed to do.
Water-resistant enough to keep ticking.
Clear enough to be read.
Recognisable long after the diver returned to the surface.